how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU everybody is very excited for the
x-men to enter the MCU finally yesterday
I did a video on what the first possible
lineup for the x-men could be in their
debut film and the comments were all
very very good everybody's really
excited to see some new x-men come to
the MCU and see some characters that
we've seen before in previous versions
with Fox but what if I told you that
Marvel Studios could not only be
planning on bringing back some of the
characters that Fox has already done but
could also be planning on bringing back
some of the actors that played those
characters now I know that a lot of
people have mixed feelings about this
some people would like an entirely new
cast and entirely new characters to come
to the MCU while others would very much
like to see these old actors and old
characters from Fox be done in the MCU
because everybody believes that Marvel
Studios could truly do these characters
justice well based off of some things
that Marvel Studios has done and based
off of some things that the actors have
said it looks like they could be
planning on bringing back some of the
original actors to reprise their roles
of the x-men so we'll break down all of
these things in this video if you're new
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter this week's giveaway to
win a Hulk Funko pop from Avengers in
game all you have to do is subscribe
like the video and comment down below
now first and foremost we already do
have some proof that Marvel Studios
would like to bring back some of the
original actors that played the x-men
forfox back to the MCU in some way shape
or form and we also have proof that
Marvel Studios definitely would do this
as they kind of already have the first
example of proof that we have is JK
Simmons reprising his role as Jay jonah
Jameson and spider-man far from home no
he is not an x-men but the principle is
basically the same he was in an old
spider-man movie that did not exist in
the MCU and they put him in a new
spider-man movie that does exist in the
MCU as the same exact character so for
anybody who says no they are not going
to bring back any of the original actors
to play their roles of the x-men in the
so you Marvel isn't thinking about that
well they kind of already have but JK
Simmons is character of Jay jonah
Jameson
although iconic isn't exactly a huge
role it's not small by any means but
it's not Patrick Stewart's Professor
Xavier now we already know and have
proof that Marvel Studios and the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
has spoken with Patrick Stewart about
coming back as a Professor Xavier and
this is confirmed we have proof Patrick
Stewart himself said it in an interview
while doing press for the upcoming Star
Trek but card series he told Digital Spy
this I met with Kevin Feige a couple of
months ago and we have long long
conversations and there have been moves
and suggestions which include Charles
Xavier here's the problem if we had not
made Logan then yes I would probably be
ready to get into that wheelchair of one
more time and be Charles Xavier but
Logan changed all that
he would go on to say that he had made
peace with departing from Professor
Xavier as he said goodbye and Logan but
the main point to take away from this is
that he said he had long conversations
with Kevin Feige and there have been
moves and suggestions which include
Charles Xavier
now this implies that Kevin Feige asked
him to come back and play Professor X
because he said if I had not made Logan
then yes I would probably be ready to
get into that wheelchair one more time
so he literally says him getting back in
that wheelchair meaning him playing the
role of Professor Xavier not somebody
else so this wasn't Kevin Feige
consulting with Patrick Stewart about a
new Professor X if this was him asking
him to come back to play Professor X in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now unfortunately Patrick Stewart
declined he's made peace with his
character and departed but he's not the
only original x-men recently James
Martin the actor who played Cyclops in
the original x-men has expressed
interest in returning to reprise his
role of Cyclops in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and in fact he said that he
still keeps in contact with Kevin Feige
in a recent interview with Screen Rant
about Sonic the Hedgehog the fact that
Patrick Stewart had met with
Kevin Feige and talked to him about
reprising the role as Professor Xavier
he was asked if he would reprise his
role as Cyclops and if he spoke into
Marvel and this was his response I would
would never be opposed to coming back I
hold a special place in my heart for
that experience I mean I look at those
three movies I was in and it was a it
became a huge part of my life it was a
family all of them so I'd be a fool to
say no to that of course I would
Feige is still friend of mine and and we
talk Cajun aliy but it's you just don't
know where it's gonna go so as you just
saw james marsden said that he would be
a fool to say no to that that if he was
asked to reprise his role as Cyclops he
would say yes now of course there is the
possibility that he's already been asked
to reprise his role because if he has
been asked he's not gonna come out and
say yeah I'm coming back a cyclops it's
great he would probably get into a lot
of trouble but Cyclops is another iconic
x-men from the original films and I'm
sure fans would love to see him come
back and it sounds like he's open to it
so it just may happen and the other day
we actually got another report that
another Fox x-men could be making his
way to the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
that is Quicksilver the other day
Murphy's multiverse composted a report
that Evan Peters the actor who played
Quicksilver and Fox's version of the
x-men has signed on for a lead role in
wann division the report says thanks to
a familiar and trusted source the same
la-based source who told me about Peyton
Reed signing on for season two of the
mandalorian I have learned that Evan
Peters signed on for a key role in the
Marvel Studios Disney Plus streaming
series Wan division the 33 year old
Peters landed the role late last year
and filmed his scenes
shortly after this was actually kind of
around the same time that Marvel Studios
was talking to Patrick Stewart asking
him to come back as Professor X could
Evan Peters be reprising his role as
Quicksilver in the one division series
if he is it actually would make a lot of
sense Quicksilver or Pedro maximov is
the brother of Wanda Maximoff The
Scarlet Witch now of course we've
already had a Quicksilver in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe played by Aaron
taylor-johnson in Marvel's Avengers age
of Ultron
but unfortunately we know how that ended
you didn't see that's coming and it
seems like in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Wanda has made her peace with
her brother being gone but what if he
comes back in a different way
we know that Wanda in the series is
going to create multiple realities and
in one of these other realities perhaps
it's possible that while she's creating
this perfect life for herself that we've
seen in the teaser so far perhaps she
brings her brother back but it's a
different version of him an alternate
version from a different reality this
could be how she kind of starts to lose
it in the Wanda vision series she starts
to try and bring people back obviously
vision comes back but while trying to
bring her brother back it doesn't go
exactly as she planned it and we get
Evan Peters as Quicksilver now
admittedly this would be very very
random on Marvel's part there would have
to be a very specific reason for them to
do this because they could just as
easily bring back Aaron taylor-johnson
because he still has projects left on
his contract so of course there is the
possibility that Evan Peters is simply
signed on to play a different role and
that role could be speed one of Wanda's
twin boys who has the powers of
Quicksilver this would obviously be a
grown up version of him but kind of
makes sense and then of course he could
be playing another character perhaps
even a villain but that's another video
but the point of this is that Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige
has talked to a previous Fox x-men actor
about coming to the MCU and if this
report is accurate he's not just talking
about it he's already filmed scenes for
the series so he's coming back in some
way shape or form now a lot of people
have been asking me about Deadpool and
don't worry Ryan Reynolds of course is
still going to be playing Deadpool
Disney Marvel and Ryan Reynolds himself
have actually been quite open about this
they've confirmed Ryan Reynolds is
playing Deadpool and they even said that
Deadpool will probably remain rated R
and right now on the production grid for
the next Deadpool film there's only two
people listed right now as the producer
Ryan Reynolds and of course Kevin Feige
so relax Ryan Reynolds is 100% returning
as Deadpool now the question is in
regards to the original
x-men how exactly are they going to
reprise their characters in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe well as sad as it is
in all honesty if Patrick Stewart would
have returned as Professor X he would
have probably just led the x-men as they
introduced the x-men in the MCU and they
introduced Professor X he would have
been played by Patrick Stewart
but what if Cyclops and other x-men
returned how would they do that well
really there are only two ways that
would make the most sense one would
simply be for the original actors to
reprise their roles and they come into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and play
these characters for another 10 years
now although I'm sure some of the actors
would be thrilled to reprise their roles
they may not be up for playing the
character for another 10 years so one of
the most likely options is that they
will simply come into play in different
universes primarily and Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness or the 1
division series both are going to deal
with different realities and alternate
universes because you have to remember
that Kevin Feige was involved with the
Fox x-men that's actually where he got
started so they hold a dear place in his
heart and perhaps he plans on giving
them a little bit of an ode a little bit
of recognition and love in his MCU films
and the way he could plan on doing that
is to simply give them little cameos and
different realities or different
universes and Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness it's either this
or they're actually going to be coming
into the MCU for a very long time but
what would you prefer would you like
some of the original x-men to come into
the new Marvel Cinematic Universe as
x-men or which you simply like them just
to be cameos let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU you can
follow me on Twitter for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof